what up gq it's yg i'm about to go
undercover on the internet
it's actually me
[Music]
first up imdb born march 1990 in banquet
california birthday and keenan and
conrad jackson
height five ten and a half no my height
is six feet
but everything else right trivia one
watching his mother's finale find a
non-profit
400 ways who mentioned this to enhance
the life
of the disadvantage huh oh youth
is supposedly you to enhance the life of
the disadvantaged youth who are part of
the foster care
group home system yes that's true 400
ways is my non-profit organization we do
a lot of work
in the inner city so the underprivileged
kids you know the ghettos
the schools the people submit twitter
anybody know how to tie a banner like yg
yeah hey yg you making
fbt part three now that's what i'm
waiting for
man it's kind of hard to try to make a
[ __ ] trump song without nip you know
i don't know yg how do you feel about
the honeys being read
i ain't mad i'll put the devil on that
thing yeah
where does he find bandana's large
enough to tie around his head
my head is too big but i want to wear
one and that style you got to know how
to fold the banana
to make it large to fit around your head
because
if you fold it like halfway it's a
perfect half and half
situation and you try to put on your
head and they're gonna work like that
you gotta figure it out
ask a girl or somebody you know females
know how to do that can we get another
album like my crazy life
yes that's gonna come very soon like i
had to get out my little
situation that i hated to really be able
to create that type of
like music again you know what i'm
saying so i'm finally out of my
situation so
coming soon my peoples bro can we get
another blame on the streets
movie the other one you did was 30
minutes but we need a full movie like
that
i feel that i'm in the works on
something like that stay tuned
just kind of have a real chilly chili
i haven't found some spot like i don't
even know what that is
[Music]
no seriously it's actually me we'll work
out that yg the rapper do
i do push-ups pull-ups sit-ups dips
bench press
and i'm about to start running submit
wise you write a song about donald trump
me and the homies kept talking about
this dude and we was feeling like
we like so we said let's go make this
home and that's why we made this song
submit
[Music]
wikipedia yg followed being died for
about three months in 2016 for citing
health reasons
yes that's true what made me go vegan
the homies stevo
and nixie hustle they basically put me
up on a guy's name
doctor seven i just felt like at the
time i was drinking a lot of alcohol
you know i was getting like you from
your alcohol belly like alcohol is not
good for you so
when you do that a lot you know you got
to know
what you're doing so i felt like i
needed to do something that was gonna
like
cleanse you know balance out like all
i'm putting in my body so i did my
homework on dr
shelley he said legit solving vegan i
did everything
they were saying to do i lost weight i
was feeling real good
my skin got clear i was barely sleeping
like i only sleep like four hours get up
full energy and now if i go vegan like
once a year for like
a month minimum you know i'm saying to
get that full body detox you feel me the
brain
like everything posted youtube laughing
out of highlighter who made this beat
that's all i want to know
the homie franchise made that beat
listen to the song
it says franchise at the beginning of
the song
essentials so why you just running this
year his home is just
spying out of nowhere here something
like that so
whoa the homies is haha whoa that's like
the call
you know that's the call what's the name
of the mother who twerks outside of the
tesla she's buying a dream about it
i don't know her name but i remember
that i was right there and i was like
damn
um i do not know baby girl's name though
why jesus brother my brother was there i
think
he was here this says it feels it not
what to do with it you gotta go vote you
know what i'm saying you gotta vote and
you gotta know
what you're voting for who you voted for
outside of the presidency you got to
vote for
like the local representatives you know
what i'm saying got something to do with
your community that can
either make a difference in the better
for your community or are they over
there
making the difference that's causing
problems defending for the
community that's what you gotta do you
know what i'm saying boom
that's it i'm signing off the internet
thank y'all